hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well Peter Singer in
his biological basis of ethics is going
to discuss reciprocal altruism and
altruism is a general designator for
behavior or motivations that make the
other the altar central in our
decision-making where we prioritize the
good the benefits the interest of the
other sometimes to the detriment of our
own but not necessarily so and singer is
interested here in not altruism just as
such but in reciprocal altruism altruism
where people are engaged in reciprocity
as a norm and he points out bringing up
a few different people different
scholars that there this is a very
universal tendency we find this across
cultures and throughout time so he
quotes sociologist Alvin Gould nur
contrary to some cultural relativist
that can be hypothesized that a norm of
reciprocity is universal that's a pretty
strong statement but he's probably right
about that it doesn't mean that
everybody follows it as we're gonna see
in just a moment but there's a norm in
place within
we have a culture so singer says it's
surprising how many features of human
ethics could have grown out of simple
reciprocal practices like for example
mutual removal of parasites from awkward
places one cannot oneself reach suppose
I want to have it's kind of a gross
example that may turn some of you off
but think about it in terms of ancient
human beings suppose I want to have the
lice in my hair picked out to obtain
this I'm willing to pick out someone
else's lice but already with that I have
to be discriminating I have to
discriminate who is going to be a good
life picker a reliable life speaker and
who is going to take my life's picking
and not reward me in the process he says
if I help everybody indiscriminately I
will find myself grooming others who
don't groom me back so to avoid this
waste of time and effort I distinguish
between those who repay me for my
assistance and those who do not in other
words he says I separate those who deal
fear fairly with me from those who cheat
those who don't repay me I shall mark
out to avoid indeed enemy go further
still reacting with anger and hostility
so if we generalize from this
relationship and we talk about anything
else you know get into advanced social
life you invite people to your party but
they don't invite you to yours to theirs
well something's wrong there right
what's going on there's an expectation
that there'll be a sort of repayment of
benefits so he says let's take
individually these these these
outgrowths of reciprocal altruism the
most crucial distinction between is
between those who it's worth my while to
assist in those who's not and we have to
think about those who are going to
actually benefit us so he says that the
practice of reciprocal altruism can
tolerate rut rough justice at this point
but we would expect that as human powers
of reason
communication increased decisions as to
what it is or is not an equitable
exchanger become more precise as we
develop our cognitive and linguistic
abilities and our culture we're able to
make finer and finer distinctions about
what we ought to get or what we ought to
give or who we want not to give anything
to and he talks about the development of
positive feelings towards those who
benefit us one of the most common of
these positive feelings is what we call
gratitude right so he quotes you know a
few people here
Polybius right who says when a man who
has been helped when endangered by
another design a tional gratitude to his
preserver but goes to the length of
attempting to do him injury it's clear
those who become aware of it will
naturally be displeased and offended by
such conduct sharing the resentment of
their injured neighbor and goes on and
on and on so he says that to say the
duty to repay benefits as the beginning
and end of justice is an overstatement
but that it is the beginning is
plausible right and wrong the notion of
what you ought to do those who actually
benefit you lose think about parents you
know giving you life nourishing you
raising you you should be grateful to
them you should be benevolent towards
them
there should be reciprocity your you
know brothers sister who hides your
stuff and picks on you and makes fun of
you with their friends maybe you know
kin altruism would say you still have to
be good to them because they're your
your kin but reciprocal altruism could
say screw you I'm not going to give you
anything you never benefit me you
actually treat me in bad ways so we have
positive feelings for those who would
benefit us and then we have negative
feelings towards those who don't
reciprocate and these negative feelings
can take the form of indignation and
they can even go to revenge and revenge
can be for not doing something for
example people get really angry when you
don't learn their names and the
is a big problem for me because I heart
remembering names including those even
of my students the older I get the the
more trouble I have with that and
monadic devices don't seem to help so I
just have to live with it right but I
should know that people may get
indignant if I if I get their name wrong
and we can go further with revenge
revenge can also be for something
somebody else did where they positively
harmed me they injured me they insulted
me they humiliated me they hindered me
they did something that made me angry
and so we have these positive and
negative feelings and he says that you
know from our positive feelings for
those who help us bring the bonds of
friendship and the loyalty we feel to
friends from our negative feelings for
those who do not reciprocate we get
moral indignation and the desire to
punish if reciprocal altruism played a
significant role in human evolution and
aversion to being cheated would be a
distinct advantage so he's saying that
you know we can hypothesize that this
became the way that we are
there's panoply of feelings that we have
as a result of people doing or not doing
things because of evolution so he says
humans have this aversion we can tell
that they do what's a good example of
this he's got a great one here people
who could not be induced to work in
hours overtime for ten dollars will
spend an hour taking back defective
goods worth five dollars and he says
anthropologist has seen this in all
sorts of other cultures people will say
things like well it's the principle of
the thing and then he asked a really
important question why do we care so
much about the principle well according
to Singer we care so much about the
principle because we feel like somebody
screwed us when we did something good to
them we gave them some money we trusted
them with you know being a consumer or
customer of them they gave us a product
that product doesn't work now we're mad
we're gonna go back and get satisfaction
well this would be from this basic
primitive biological evolution
a basis according to two singer now it
gets yet more interesting and more
complicated
he says when we think of ourselves as
particularly communicative beings so he
brings up two things here he says
personal resentments transforms into
moral indignation when it's shared by
other members of a group and brought
under a general principle because we can
imagine ourselves in the position of
others and we can formulate general
rules which deal with these cases our
own personal feelings of resentment may
solidify into a group code with socially
accepted standards of what constitutes
adequate return for a service and what
should be done to those who cheat the
other thing you says is because we
communicate we can move from a what he
calls bilateral to multilateral
relationship if I help you but you don't
help me not only can i you know how to
count on others like looking at that and
being like that guy's a jerk they're
gonna say that guy's a jerk and then
even people out of the immediate
situation are gonna be like oh there's
that guy who's a jerk I'm not helping
that jerk and it can go on and on for
you know for a long time as a matter of
fact it could be targeted to people
belonging to an entire family group for
four generations so he says if if I help
you but you don't help me I can cease to
help you in the future if I can talk it
can do more I can tell everyone in the
group what sort of a person you are then
they will be less likely to help you in
the future but I can also do the reverse
we can ask is someone a reliable
reciprocate err we can you know check
their reputation we can see how they've
done with other people and this is what
we in fact do when we get references or
when we're relying on reviews is it not
we're seeing whether other people
fulfilled their agreements so he's got
this great example here he's
if I once saved a person from drowning
and a man and I'm in need of rescue
myself I will be lucky indeed if the
very person I rescued is within earshot
but if the heroic deed is known only to
that person I saved it's unlikely to
have any future benefits on the other
hand if everybody else in the community
knows that I jumped into a raging river
to save the child well then I get a
reputation and then they're going to say
we want to help this guy out and so
reciprocal altruism is you could say
magnified by our communicational and
cognitive Nexus that develops over time
singer thinks that reciprocal altruism
is indeed a strong norm that runs
through practically every culture he
doesn't think that everybody is
reciprocally
altruistic because there are some who
try to cheat and then they get punished
as a result not necessarily with perfect
consistency but with enough regularity
to maintain these norms
you